[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro 2 checkup votre magazine santé et
bien-être attrape un nouveau centre de
santé municipal a ouvert ses portes au
début du mois d'avril nous nous sommes
rendus sur place pour en savoir plus
nous découvrirons également une méthode
naturelle qui permet de mieux assimiler
l'oxygène que nous respirons ce sont les
bols d' jaquier mais tout d'abord place
au premier sujet c'est devenu un
rendez-vous régulier chaque mois nous
partons en immersion dans l'un des
services de l'hôpital privé de l'Ouest
parisien de trappe cette fois-ci nous
avons suivi le quotidien du service
réanimation et limoine pour les
images Lucy oui salut comment tu vas ça
s'est bien passé çaté ça a été tu as pas
fait d'entrée c'est le même rituel
chaque matin Lucy a travaillé toute la
nuit elle passe maintenant le relais à
sa collègue j'avais augmenté 15 laad à
21h au service réanimation samia est la
doyenne des infirmières depuis 26 ans
elle voit passer ses patients le plus
souvent envoyés par le samuou les
urgences ici chaque malade a un ou
plusieurs organes défaillants mettant
directement le pronostic
vital minutes après son arrivée Samia
fait un tour des patients dont elle est
en charge l'aide soignante assure ce
qu'on appelle les constantes telles que
la prise de température le pou ou encore
l'attention Samia elle fait ensuite un
premier bilan et donne les
médicaments vous savez que vous passez
au bloc
aujourd'hui oui donc pas de petit-
déjeuner on avait dit au même moment les
réanimateurs eux aussi sont en pleine
visite ils sont ici en unité de soins
continu
la plart des patients sont passés par le
service de réanimation mais nécessitent
encore une surveillance rapprochée un
cardiologue les accompagne ce matin à
chaque fois que ça ça va pas bien et que
c'est préoccupant éventuellement pour la
vie du du patient les les collègues de
toutes les
spécialités sont obligés ou viennent
travailler avec nous et c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui est
passionnant avant de faire venir les
cègues c'est le réanimateur qui prend en
charge les défaillances du patient celui
qui étouffe et qui n'arrive plus à
respirer celui qui a des reins
défaillants ou encore celui qui est en
plein coma autant de situations que le
réanimateur s géré dans chaque cas ce
qui est passionnant c'est de c'est
trouver la la cause de la défaillance
qui est pas toujours évidente qui est
parfois un peu caché qu'il faut chercher
elle est détendue par rapport à hier où
elle était un petit peu inconfort table
aujourd'hui elle est un petit peu enfin
dans la nuit ça c'est elle c'est
beaucoup plus détendue elle est un peu
un peu mieux l'équipe ne prend pas
seulement en charge les patients elles
s'occupent aussi de leurs proches
souvent quand le service est extrêmement
lourd et on peut avoir trois patients
pour une seule infirmière o on passe de
chambre en chambre avec des malades qui
sont essentiellement plongés dans le
coma et le risque c'est de perdre ce
côté humain de voilà de voir une maladie
de voir des machines et on communique
qu'en résultat en chiffres en machine et
cetera il y a quelque chose qui nous
rattrape assez rapidement c'est quand
même le le les familles l'année dernière
20 % des patients admis dans ce service
réanimation ont succombé à leur maladie
paradoxalement plus ce taux est élevé
meilleur est le service car cela veut
dire qu'il gère des patients plus graves
que les autres on gagne pas toujours en
réanimation et donc dans ces cas-là le
fait de pas gagner d'avoir à annoncer
une mauvaise nouvelle au aux familles
d'annoncer un décès ça fait partie du
travail mais c'est toujours ça donne
toujours une décharge émotionnelle
importante parce qu'on on peut pas
rester indifférent en annonçant un décès
avec des gens qui sont catastrophés ou
même
si assez souvent c'est c'était attendu
même si on l'avait expliqué aux gens la
quand on est confronté au décès on est
on est tout malgré tout jamais prêt et
les familles sont sont bien sûr
bouleversé ils n'ont pas peur de le dire
la mort fait partie de leur quotidien et
planent sur le service fort heureusement
certaines victoires leur permettent de
continuer à avancer quand on voit un
patient qui est là depuis longtemps ou
qui a été entre la vie et la mort
pendant quelques jours et qui et qui
s'en sort c'est c'est une raison de
vivre Gill est arrivé ici il y a près de
2 mois pour cause de détresse
respiratoire il ne parlait pas et ne
pouvait pas manger plongé dans un
semicomat pendant plus d'un mois il est
aujourd'hui réveiller pendant que je
faisais le roi voilà j'avais toutes mes
princesses autour de moi qui
s'occupaient de moi et j'ai le plaisir
de le
découvrir il revient de loin l'équipe
estime aujourd'hui qu'il est sur la
bonne voie et qu'il pourrait bientôt
rentrer chez lui les infirmières sont
vraiment agréables
elles sont là vraiment pour nous
accompagner
et on n pas des malades pour eux on est
vraiment des gens à part entière et euh
elles nous font participer à notre à
notre problème et grâce à ça je crois
que c'est ça qui donne l'envie d'avancer
encore plus avancer encore plus et
avancer ensemble le mot d'ordre ici est
le travail d'équipe infirmière aide
soignante et réanimateur sont très
complémentaires en fin de matinée tous
se retrouvent pour ce qu'ils appellent
le staff ouais là donc réveil extubation
et et PM réglé à 50
il faut un premier point sur les h
patients du service réanimation et sur
les 12 autres de l'unité de soins
continu en ayant toujours un œil sur eux
grâce à cet écran de
vidéosurveillance contrairement à
d'autres services les malades en
réanimation ne sont pas autonomes
souvent ce sont des malades qui sont
techniqués donc sous machine plongé dans
des comass artificiels donc il suffit
qu'un malade soit s'agite soit s'extube
soit se débranche de sa machine et là ça
peut être
avir des conséquences beaucoup plus
dramaties l'urgence fait également
partie intégrante du service chaque
matin une infirmière veille à ce que le
matériel soit bien fonctionnel sur ce
chariot d'urgence il y a notamment un
défibrillateur en cas de souc cardiaque
et plus loin ses obus pour apporter de
l'oxygène au patients en cas de
transfert il y a toujours un stress même
si on le ressent pas au sein des équipes
il est intérieur on le refoule mais il
est là bon je prépare votre dossier pour
le bloc
réanimateur depuis plus de 15 ans
Jean-François voit passer environ 450
patients chaque année quand on lui
demande ce qu'il y a de plus compliqué
il évoque clairement le partage du temps
entre vie professionnelle et vie privée
mes enfants qu' le qu' dans Entre 20 25
30 ans quand ils m'ont dit un jour papa
moi je ferai parer animateur parce que
je voudrais voir mes enfants je me suis
pris ça dans la tête et je me suis dit
que ça c'est lourd pour la la vie
familiale
mais bon c'est c'est un métier qui donne
qui donne des joies énormes immenses je
pense c'est un des plus beaux métiers de
au sein de la au sein de la
médecine il est midi l'heure du déjeuner
est aussi appelée heure d'astreinte car
ils ne quittent pas le service et ont
toujours un œil sur leurs patients le
repas est souvent ponctué d'aller-retour
mais peu importe la passion les anime
tous dans cette grande famille
[Musique]
ro
depuis le 9 avril un nouveau centre de
santé municipal a ouvert ses portes rug
Gandi à trpe les patients afflu déjà les
images sont signées Mélanie
poet des locaux flamb en neuf une
surface de 400 m Carr attrape le nouveau
centre de santé municipal a ouvert ses
portes il y a près d'un mois la règle
d'or ici les consultations sont
conventionnées secteur 1 et le tir
payant est appliqué quel que soit le
niveau de revenu le niveau de vie de
tout les habitants qu'il puissent avoir
qu'il soit menti ou non qu'il puisse
avoir des soins qui soit d'aussi bonne
qualité que si vous alliez dans un
cabinet en libéral ou ou à l'hôpital
privé de l'Ouest parisien et cetera
médecin généraliste gynécologue
orthophoniste ou encore allergologue 11
professionnels de santé accueille les
patients tous sont en temps partiel et
travaillaient déjà à l'ancien centre de
santé Yve Lafarge centre d'attente de
plus de 40 ans devenu très obsolète et
aujourd'hui définitivement fermé on a
retrouvé d'abord un peu plus d'espace
hein puisque effectivement on est dans
des locaux neufs là-bas ifarge c'était
deux appartements là on a la lumière qui
arrive
partout on a des locaux qui sont quand
même plus plus aérés et cetera
maintenant les les personnes qui sont
sur chaise roulante il peuvent rentrer
aussi voilà on est au normes donc c'est
vrai que c'est pour nous quelque chose
d'important 2 million et demi d'euros
c'est le coût global de cette nouvelle
structure l'état la communauté
d'agglomération ou encore la région on
participer au financement et la ville de
trappe est majoritaire à plus de 50 %.
les patients sont au rendez-vous les
délais d'attente s'allongent déjà des
recrutements pourraient être envisagés à
court
[Musique]
terme un mode de vie stressant une
atmosphère polluée autant de paramètres
qui nous empêchent de bien assimiler
l'oxygène une méthode naturelle permet
de lutter contre ce cela ce sont les
bols d'air jaquier nous sommes partis à
la rencontre des professionnels de santé
yvelinois qui proposent cette méthode à
leurs patients vous allez vous mettre à
10 cm à peu près du petit respirateur et
puis je vous programme pour 3 minutes 3
minutes pour respirer les vapeurs
dégagées et une sensation de bien-être à
la clé naturopathe à Versailles Sophie
propose des séances de bol d'air jaquier
depuis qu'elle s'est installée il y a 3
ans via cet appareil qui utilise un
composé de résine de pain alors d'entrer
quand les gens viennent ils viennent
d'une vie stressante pollué et donc ça
permet de de se poser ça permet de se
poser de de retrouver un peu de calme en
eux des grandes respiration profonde
pour que ça permette bien à l'oxygène de
pénétrer Marjorie est asthmatique sa
naturopathe lui propose une séance de
bol d'air avant et après chaque
consultation donc c'est qu'on a
l'impression de se balader dans une
pined ça fait tourner la tête un petit
peu parce que on a vraiment l'impression
de prendre justement un bol d' ça porte
bien son nom de plein fouet depuis 25
ans c'est la société hist qui
commercialise ces appareils nous avons
rencontré la gérante lors d'un salon à
Paris le bol d'air c'est un dispositif
qui va permettre de transformer
certaines molécules aromatiques issu de
la résine de pain donc qui se trouve
dans ce dans cette huile essentielle les
principes actifs de l'huile essentielle
de résine de pain vont être transformé
en porteur d'oxygène en respirant les
vapeurs il pénètre dans l'organisme et
délivre de l'oxygène via
l'hémoglobine c'est le principe
d'oxygénation cellulaire naturelle
l'organisme se défend alors plus
facilement contre les radicaux libres il
a un effet sur la fatigue chronique sur
le sommeil sur l'endormissement sur le
stress en général les sportifs également
utilisent le bol d'air pour faciliter
l'entraînement et améliorer la
récupération ce n'est pas un médicament
ni un traitement médical beaucoup de
gens pratique le Boulder au quotidien
avec un appareil à domicile d'une valeur
de 1640 €. on le trouve aussi en
location dans des lieux spécialisés ou
encore chez des professionnels de santé
évelinois comme ici chez cette
ostéopathe à Montini le Bretonneux pour
de réels effets plusieurs séances de 3
minutes sont recommandées tous les
[Musique]
jours avant de nous quitter vous le
savez voici quelques dates santé à
retenir le mardi 19 et le mercredi 20
mai une collecte de 100 est organisée à
Montini le Bretonneux rendez-vous à
proximité du centre commercial un
véhicule de l'Établissement français du
sang sera stationné à l'angle de la rue
Gustave Eiffel le mercredi 20 mai
l'association imagine for Margot propose
un événement au profit des enfants
malades cette match pour des enfants
sans cancer ce sera à partir de 14h au
club les pyramides au Port Marly au
programme des animations pour les
enfants et des activités diverses avec
des personnalités du sport et du
spectacle checkup c'est terminé merci de
votre attention je vous donne
rendez-vous dans un mois d'ici là
portez-vous
[Musique]
bien